-Our next guest is
an Academy Award
and Grammy winner,
a Rock and Roll Hall of Fame
inductee,
and former frontman
of Talking Heads.
His latest work,
"Here Lies Love,"
is playing at the
Broadway Theatre on Broadway.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend David Byrne.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back.
-Thank you!
-I'm so happy you're here.
-[ Laughs ]
I'm glad to be here.
-And I know every time
you're here,
and it's the way you get
everywhere in New York City,
you biked here today.
-Yeah.
It's locked outside.
So, you, David Byrne,
bike to 30 Rock,
and then you just
locked it outside?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And how recognizable
are you to people
as David Byrne on a bike?
-Most of the time, no,
but somehow they know
when I'm coming to do this show.
-Yes. Interesting.
'Cause you wear a helmet,
obviously.
You play it safe.
-Most of the time, yeah.
-Okay. Most of the time.
-Yeah, most.
-Have you --
Is the biking a new thing,
or have you always been
a New York City biker?
-I've been doing it
for a long time.
Used to live on the
Lower East Side back in the --
-Yeah.
-A long time ago.
There were hardly
any cabs down there.
-Gotcha.
-Hardly any cabs in SoHo.
It was like this weird,
dangerous, whatever.
-So it was out of necessity
that you were a biker?
-Kind of, yeah.
It became really practical.
-And it's become safer.
I think New York City has gotten
a little bit better for bikers,
but not entirely safe.
-Not entirely.
I wouldn't go to a friend
and say --
who's never done it and say,
"Oh, just go ahead,
just go ahead.
Just jump in there."
[ Laughter ]
-Because you -- I know
when you went on tour,
you and your cast
would bike in other cities.
-Yeah.
-So it must be nice.
There must be some
American cities where you go,
"Oh, one day.
Wouldn't it be great
if New York was like this?"
-Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean, there --
Austin has -- amazingly
has incredible bike lanes.
Portland, of course,
of "Portlandia," yes.
Lots of bike lanes.
[ Laughter ]
-They do.
So, congratulations.
Your second Broadway show.
-Yes.
Well, yes, it is.
-As a guy who used to bike
around the Lower East Side,
did you ever think you'd have
two Broadway shows?
-Uh, br-br-br-br, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, this is based on an album
you did with Fatboy Slim?
It is a --
It's about Imelda Marcos,
the wife of the former dictator
in the Philippines.
-Exactly.
-And what made you first think
that this would be
a good topic for -- of music?
-Just cried out to me. Yes.
No. I'd been to --
Way back in the day,
I'd been to some discos,
but I usually just went to see
if there was a musical act
performing.
And the acts who had club hits
in those days
would come into the disco,
stand on a little platform,
put in a tape that had their
backing tracks of their song,
and just sing their two hits,
and they'd be gone.
And I thought,
"But what if they could do more?
What if you could do
a whole evening
and tell a story that way
while the audience is dancing?"
I like the idea of, "What
if you can have an audience
that's only half
paying attention?"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Somehow that appealed to me.
And -- because I thought,
"They'll absorb it.
They'll absorb the story.
They don't have to be
just paying attention
every second."
Put that in my back pocket.
And then years later,
I read that Imelda Marcos
loved going to clubs.
She had a mirror ball installed
in her New York townhouse,
which we don't all have.
-No, we don't all have.
-No, not all of us.
-We all should, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I googled that up and saw
a video of her dancing
under her home mirror ball
with Khashoggi, the arms dealer.
-Wow.
-Yeah, and I thought,
"Uh, she lives in this world
that I've been thinking about
if there could be
a show that way.
And look who she's dancing with.
There's a story here."
-So -- So it just clicks
together like that.
-Yeah. So I can bring
these two ideas together,
these two things together,
and let's see what happens.
Let's see if there's a story.
-And again, so I'm going
to show a photo.
This is a Broadway theater
here in New York City.
You've taken out all the seats
so that the audience
on the ground floor there,
in the orchestra area,
just sort of dances
throughout
the course of the show.
-Yes.
So, we actually --
I mean, okay.
If you don't want to dance,
you don't have to.
There are seats.
-Yes.
-There are seats.
-There's nice balcony seats,
so you don't have
to be with this...
-But my dream came true,
and I could do a show
where a good portion
of the audience is...
-Yeah.
-...able to dance.
-It must make you so happy
to see that this idea you had
all those years ago
is paying off.
And it's
an entirely Filipino cast.
That must be an exciting thing
to put together.
-That's very exciting.
They're kind of telling
their own -- the story
of their own country.
-Uh-huh.
And do you feel like --
I mean, obviously, people
who buy Broadway tickets,
you know, they maybe aren't
expecting something like this.
Do you feel like
you've prepared them enough
for what they're about
to walk in for?
-I hope so.
I hope when they go
to buy the tickets,
they read the thing that says
"If you buy a ticket
on the dance floor,
you will be standing
for an hour and a half,
but you're not
gonna miss anything."
It's all happening
all around you.
But if you want a seat, there's
lots of ways to sit, as well.
Yeah, I haven't --
I go about once a week.
-That's exciting.
-And I usually go on the dance
floor because I just --
I feel like I'm immersed.
I'm in it, then.
-Well, I feel like
you are someone
who has always
seemed to be taken over by music
and wanted to dance.
-I always wanted to, yes.
-Yeah.
That's why we --
[ Laughter ]
That's why we never play music
during the interviews.
Because we're afraid
you'll just wander off, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I always ask people like this,
especially ones
who've had such long,
iconic careers.
Do you ever hear when
you're at a cafe or in a car,
do you ever hear your music?
And what is your reaction
when you hear songs of yours?
-If I heard it,
sometimes friends point it out.
I don't notice.
-Really.
-I don't notice.
I have it tuned out.
It's like another part of my
brain or -- for musicians.
They start to they listen
to music
in a different way.
And my friends will point --
"David, David, David,
listen to that.
Do you know who that is?"
[ Laughter ]
-This sounds like they're
giving you an Alzheimer's test.
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
-Now this --
We've talked about this before.
For my money,
one of the best --
the greatest
concert movie of all time.
"Stop Making Sense"
was just re-released.
They were showing it
in theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Remastered.
-Thank you!
And you went.
You watched it.
-Oh, I've watched it, yeah,
now, a few times
during the opening.
That was a couple weeks ago.
-How many years had it been
since you've seen it?
-It had been at least
10 years,
maybe 15, since I'd seen it
projected on a screen.
And when it got reprinted
from the mast--
from the negative
and remixed and everything,
I obviously went to
a screening, and I thought,
"Wow, this looks great.
It sounds great,
but who is that guy?"
[ Laughter ]
He's a very serious young man.
He's very intent.
Is he having any fun?
And --
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
-It is -- I will say,
because obviously --
I've met this era David Byrne
is who I met.
And you were not
who I thought you'd be
based on that era David Byrne,
who seemed like
he had a sense of humor
because there was something
so theatrical about the film
and the performance that I --
You know, look, giant suit.
That's really funny.
You know what I mean?
-Yes.
-I feel like a serious guy
doesn't wear a giant suit
unless he knows there's
something funny about it.
But were you having fun?
Like, when you -- I mean,
I know it doesn't look --
But was your memory of it
before you saw it, do you think,
"Oh, my God,
that was so much fun to do"?
-Yes. At the end --
As the show progresses,
I do loosen up,
and I'm having fun,
and the music is just --
I'm just carried away by it.
So, yes,
I am having fun, but...
I'm also,
like a lot of performers,
I'm thinking, "Okay.
What do I do next?
What happens next?
Where am I supposed to be?
What's going on?"
Yeah, there's a little bit
of that going on.
-And was it different -- or, was
there a heightened sense of that
because you knew, "This time
we're putting it on film"?
Obviously, you've performed
those songs before,
but did you know the whole time,
"There's cameras here.
This is the one for..."?
-[ Inhales sharply ]
Uh...
yeah, but then, after a while,
you have to just
kind of go with it.
You just have to go,
like, "We're doing a show.
I'm playing to the audience,
not to the cameras."
Yeah.
-We did an episode based on this
starring Fred Armisen.
Fred wrote it,
called "Final Transmission."
And did you know --
-[ Laughs ]
-So here's you guys.
And, uh -- and then
here's Fred and Bill Hader.
And there's Maya Rudolph.
There's Bill Hader.
Did you know Fred
had a David Byrne impression?
-Yes, I did.
[ Laughter ]
But I --
I found out by accident.
I went to a fairly small club
downtown
to see a musical act
at one point,
and Fred was the opening act.
And I'm there in the club,
and I'm watching him do me.
And I --
-By the way, so doing comedy
before a music show
is one of the hardest
things in the world.
The only person I've ever seen
do it well is Fred.
-Fred can do it.
-Because Fred does --
He is a musician, as well.
-Yeah.
-And so Fred does exactly
what a music crowd wants to see.
Because a comedy --
if you went to a comedy club
and did a David Byrne
impression,
it might be a crazy bad idea.
But you do a David Byrne
impression
at a comedy s--
at a rock show,
it might actually work.
But he didn't know
you were there?
-He did other things, too,
but he didn't know I was there.
I'm watching.
I'm thinking, "He's doing me."
[ Laughter ]
"And he's good at it."
After the thing --
He didn't know I was there.
-Yeah.
-He came out.
I'm still in the audience.
He goes,
"David, I'm really sorry."
[ Laughter ]
"I hope that didn't bother you
too much."
No, I just said --
-You should have told him,
like, one of my friends
called me and told me
you were doing it,
and I came down..."
[ Laughter ]
"...to confront you."
Well, Fred is not alone.
We're all such huge fans
of yours.
It was so cool to pay homage
to that wonderful film,
and I'm so glad people
could see it again.
And it's just so lovely
to have you here.
Two Broadway shows.
You're finally making good.
David Byrne, everybody.
"Here Lies Love" is exceptional.
It's playing
at the Broadway Theatre.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."